>>> LESS THAN A DAY AFTER A
FEDEL JUDGE ORDERED THEM TO DO
IT, THE FORMER PRESIDENT'SOP
TWO WHITE HOUSE LAWYERS WENT
BACK BEFORE A WHITE HOUSE GRAND
JURY.
PATRICK FILLMAN ARRIVING AT
LUNCHTIME.
HIS FORMER BOSS PAT CIPOLLONE
TESTIFYING EARLIER.
BOTH MEN DECLINED TO ANSWER
CERTAIN QUESTIONS CITING THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S CLAIMS OF
EXECUTIVE AND ATTORNEY-CLIENT
PRIVILEGE.
IN THE MEANTIME THE HOUSE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE MET TODAY
ON WHETHER TO DEFER CRIMINAL
CHARGES AGAINST THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND OTHERS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
SARA MURRAY HAS BEEN DOING
REPORTING ON THIS.
SHE JOINS US NOW.
DO WE KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT PAT
CIPOLLONE'S APPEARANCE TO THE
GRAND JURY TODAY?
>> WHAT PROSECUTORS WANT IS MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT CONVERSATIONS
THESE TWO MEN HAD WITH FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP DIRECTLY AND
ADVICE THEY GAVE HIM.
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THEY TOLD THE GRAND JURY.
THOSE PROCEEDINGS ARE SECRET,
BUT WE KNOW THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO DONALD
TRUMP IN THE FINAL DAYS IN THE
AFTERMATH WHEN HE LOST THE
PRESIDENCY.
WE KNOW CIPOLLONE PUSHED BACK ON
A NUMBER OF EFFORTS TRUMP WAS
MAKING TO TRY TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
WE KNOW HE AND PHILBIN BOTH
PUSHED BACK.
OBVIOUSLY THEY HAVE A LOT OF
INFORMATION, A LOT OF FRONT ROW
INSIGHTS PROSECUTORS WANT AS
THEY DELVE INTO EFFORTS TO
SUBVERT THIS PEACEFUL TRANSITION
OF POWER.
>> THE HOUSE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE IS EXPECTED TO WRAP UP
THE INVESTIGATION, DELIVER A
FINAL REPORT.
WHAT'S EXACTLY LEFT TO FINALIZE?
>> THEY KNOW IT'S CRUNCH TIME
AND THEY HAVE A LOT LEFT TO
FINALIZE.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW THEY
NEED TO GET THIS OFF TO THE
PRINTER BUT THEY HAVEN'T DONE
THAT YET.
THEY NEED TO MAKE A DECISION ON
CRIMINAL REFERRALS.
WE'VE HEARD THEM TALKING ABOUT
THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN, HOW IT
COULD SEND SUCH A POWERFUL
SIGNAL.
EVEN THOUGH DOJ IS NOT TAKING
CUES FROM THE COMMITTEE THEY
FEEL LIKE IT COULD SEND A
POWERFUL SIGNAL ABOUT THEIR
WORK.
THEY ALSO HAVE TO DECIDE WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO ABOUT REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS, PEOPLE LIKE KEVIN
McCARTHY, PEOPLE LIKE JIM JORDAN
WHO SNUBBED THE COMMITTEE'S
SUBPOENAS.
DO THEY WANT TO TRY TO HOLD THEM
IN CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS, OR DO
NOTHING BECAUSE REPUBLICANS WERE
GOING TO TAKE CONTROL IN
JANUARY?
THEY HAVE A COUPLE MORE WEEKS TO
MAKE THESE DECISIONS.
AGAIN, YOU CAN TELL IN EVERY
CONVERSATION WITH THEM THEY KNOW
THEY'RE GOING DOWN TO THE WIRE.
>> SARA MURRAY, APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
MORE ON ALL THAT AS WELL AS THE
11th COURT OF APPEALS
OVERTURNING THE SPECIAL MAST IN
THE MAR-A-LAGO DOCUMENTS CASE
AND THE REBUKE TO THE FEDERAL
JUDGE WHO ORDERED IT.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL JIM
DEAN JOINS US NOW.
JOHN, HOW MUCH MORE JEOPARDY IN
YOUR OPINION COULD THE FORMER
PRESIDENT BE IN NOW THAT PAT
CIPOLLONE AND PATRICK PHILBIN
HAVE APPEARED BEFORE THE FEDERAL
GRAND JURY?
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT WOULD
CHANGE IN THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
TALK ABOUT THINGS THEY HADN'T
BEEN WILLING TO TALK ABOUT
BEFORE BECAUSE OF PRESIDENTIAL
PRIVILEGE?
>> I THINK WHAT THEY WERE DOING,
ANDERSON, WAS WAITING FOR A
JUDGE TO ORDER THEM TO SPEAK.
THEY WERE -- THEY HAD A
COMMITMENT UNDER THE
ATTORNEY-CLIENT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE THEY COULD HAVE
DECIDED WE'RE NOT GOING TO HONOR
THAT.
BUT THE ATTORNEY-CLIENT THEY
DON'T THROW OFF QUITE AS EASILY.
SO WHAT THE GRAND JURY GOT WAS A
LOT OF FIRST-HAND INFORMATION
WHAT THEY HAD TOLD THE
PRESIDENT, THE PRESIDENT'S
REACTION THERE TO ALL THE THINGS
SARAH NICELY SUMMARIZED.
AND THAT'S A LOT OF INFORMATION
THAT THE GRAND JURY DID NOT
HAVE.
SO THIS TO ME WOULD INCREASE MR.
TRUMP'S JEOPARDY CONSIDERABLY.
>> SO JUST TO BE CLEAR, JOHN,
YOU THINK THAT BECAUSE THE JUDGE
RULED IN THIS AND SENT THEM BACK
TO TESTIFY THEY WOULD SAY
THINGS, FOR INSTANCE, THEY
WOULDN'T SAY TO THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE BECAUSE OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT NAILS IT.
>> ON THE MAR-A-LAGO DOCUMENTS
CASE WERE YOU SURPRISED AT THE
RULING AT ALL?
>> NO, I WASN'T SURPRISED.
YOU KNOW, TO SOME DEGREE TRUMP
HAS BEEN ABLE -- TRUMP'S LAWYERS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PLAY OUT THIS
STRING.
AND, YOU KNOW, BECAUSE YOU ARE
JOURNALISTS AND YOU WANT TO GIVE
DUE TO WHAT THEY WERE FILING,
THEY WERE FILING DOCUMENTS,
WHICH, YOU KNOW, TO ANYBODY WHO
KNEW ANYTHING, MADE NO SENSE.
THE NOTION THAT ANY CRIMINAL
DEFENDANT AFTER A SEARCH CAN GO
INTO A COURT AND SAY STOP THE
PRESSES HERE, I WANT TO LOOK AT
ALL THE DOCUMENTS, GIVE ME BACK
THE DOCUMENTS, I WANT TO SEE
WHETHER YOU SEE THINGS THAT YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE SEIZED.
AND ANY CRIMINAL DEFENDANT --
LET ME ACTUALLY CHANGE THAT.
ANYBODY WHO HAS A SEARCH BEFORE
THEY WERE INDICTED HAD RIGHTS TO
CONTROL THE INVESTIGATION IS
ABSURD.
THERE'S CERTAINLY
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGES.
LAW FIRMS GET SPECIAL MASTERS,
BUT NO ONE HAD EVER BEEN TREATED
THIS WAY.
AND IF THE FORMER PRESIDENT
SAYS, YOU KNOW, HE'S TREATED
WORSE BECAUSE HE'S A FORMER
PRESIDENT AND HE'S TRUMP, IT'S
ACTUALLY THE REVERSE.
THESE DOCUMENTS WERE CONSIDERED
AND DIG IFNIFIED AND THE 11th
CIRCUIT FINALLY SAID AS THE
DISTRICT COURT JUDGE SHOULD HAVE
SAID ENOUGH, THIS IS ABSURD.
>> AND I UNDERSTAND YOU'VE GIVEN
CONSIDERATION TO WHERE CHARGES
MIGHT ULTIMATELY BE BROUGHT
AGAINST THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
THERE'S PALM BEACH.
THAT'S WHERE MAR-A-LAGO IS
LOCATED.
OR IN DECEMBER WHERE HE REMOVED
THE DOCUMENTS, WHERE THE
DOCUMENTS WERE REMOVED FROM.
>> THAT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO BE A
COMPLICATED QUESTION, AND I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE ALL THE
FACTS TO ANSWER IT.
ON THE SURFACE HERE THERE WAS
CLEARLY ILLEGAL RETENTION OF
NATIONAL DEFENSE INFORMATION AND
DOCUMENTS THAT DIDN'T BELONG TO
HIM AFTER HE LEFT THE
PRESIDENCY.
THAT RETENTION, THE HOLDING --
THE WITHHOLDING OF THAT, THE
CONCEALING OF THAT TAKES PLACE
IN MAR-A-LAGO.
BUT THE TAKING OF THE DOCUMENTS
STARTED IN D.C. BUT ARGUABLY
STARTED WHEN HE WAS STILL
PRESIDENT AND HAD A RIGHT TO
THESE DOCUMENTS.
THE TESTIMONY OF PAT CIPOLLONE
AND OTHERS MIGHT HELP UNDERSTAND
WHETHER THERE WAS A CONSPIRACY
TO ILLEGALLY RETAIN THE
DOCUMENTS THAT BEGAN IN THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA.
IF THAT'S SO, THEN THE CHARGES
CAN BE BROUGHT IN THE DISTRICT
OF COLUMBIA, WHICH, YOU KNOW,
ONE THING WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN,
BY THE WAY, IS EVEN IF THE
CHARGES WERE BROUGHT IN PALM
BEACH, I DON'T THINK JUDGE CANON
WOULD BE SITTING ON THIS CASE.
BUT THE 11th CIRCUIT SLAP DOWN
ESSENTIALLY SAYING YOU HAD NO
JURISDICTION TO DO WHAT YOU'RE
DOING, I THINK SHOULD FORECLOSE
HER SITTING ON THE CASE IN THE
FUTURE.
>> WHO DECIDES SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, THOUGH?
>> LET'S SAY THE VENUE ISSUE IS
SOMETHING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS TO DECIDE.
WHAT WERE THE ACTS COMMITTED --
>> WHO DECIDES IF IT DOES GO TO
FLORIDA WHO WOULD MAKE THE
DECISION, WELL, THE JUDGE WHO
MADE THIS, YOU KNOW,
INAPPROPRIATE RULING BEFORE
SHOULDN'T GET THE CASE?
>> WELL, WHAT HAPPENS IT GOES
INTO A DRAW.
IT GOES INTO ESSENTIALLY A
LOTTERY.
AND IF SHE WOUND UP GETTING THE
CASE AGAIN THERE WOULD CERTAINLY
BE MOTIONS TO DISQUALIFY HER,
AND THEN THE CHIEF JUDGE OF THE
CIRCUIT COULD WEIGH IN AND SAY,
YOU KNOW, YOU SHOULD BE
DISQUALIFIED.
UNLIKE THE SUPREME COURT -- I
HAVE TO SAY THIS -- THERE ARE
ETHICS RULES THAT APPLY TO THE
DISTRICT COURT AND ARE ACTUALLY
ENFORCED.
>> SO, JOHN, WITH THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE DO YOU THINK --
YOU KNOW, THERE'S THE QUESTION
OF WHETHER THEY WILL SUBMIT
SOMETHING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ABOUT PROSECUTION.
THEY DON'T NEED TO.
IT'S NOT LIKE THE DOJ IS WAITING
AROUND FOR A REFERRAL FROM THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
DO YOU THINK THIR THEIR FINAL
REPORT IS GOING TO FOCUS ON THE
FORMER PRESIDENT HIMSELF AS
OPPOSED TO THE TOTALITY OF
EVENTS ON THAT DAY?
>> I THINK THAT IS THE CASE.
CERTAINLY THERE'S SOME RUMBLING
THE STAFF WAS UNHAPPY ABOUT THE
FOCUS OF THE FINAL REPORT, THAT
IT DID FOCUS ON TRUMP TOO MUCH.
BUT ON THIS ISSUE OF REFERRAL,
THERE'S PROBABLY A PRETTY GOOD
CONSENSUS THAT THEY WILL MAKE
REFERRAL.
AND THE REASON I THINK THAT'S
THE CASE IS BECAUSE THEY'VE GOT
OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE AND IT
WILL BE MORE THAN DONALD TRUMP.
IT'LL BE OTHER PLAYERS THAT WE
HEARD LESS ABOUT THAT THEY WILL
MAKE THOSE REFERRALS.
NOW, JUSTICE DOESN'T HAVE TO --
THEY CANNOT TOTALLY IGNORE THAT
INFORMATION, BUT WHAT IT DOES IS
AFFECTS THE PUBLIC PERCEPTION OF
THE CASE, I THINK THAT COULD PUT
A LITTLE WIND BEHIND THE SAIL OF
THE DEPARTMENT IF THEY MAKE THE
REFERRALS.
>> ON THE FLIP SIDE OF THAT DO
YOU THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WANTS TO A GET A
REFERRAL FROM THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE JUST IN TERMS OF THE
OPTICS OF IT?
SHOULD IT GIVE A WHIFF OF
POLITICS TO SOMETHING MERRICK
GARLAND IS TRYING TO KEEP
APOLITICAL.
>> ON THE OTHER HAND THE JANUARY
6th REPORT IF IT'S ANYTHING LIKE
THE LIVE TESTIMONY WILL TELL A
COMPLETE NARRATIVE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS UNABLE
TO TELL IN THE CONFINES OF A
FORMAL INDICTMENT.
THEY CAN SAY MUCH MORE --
>> THEY CAN TELL THE STORY
ESSENTIALLY.
>> THEY CAN TELL THE STORY AS
THEY REALLY HAVE IN SORT OF THE
WAY JOURNALISTS TELL THE STORY.
YOU KNOW, THE LEGAL PROCEEDINGS
ARE MUCH MORE STRUCTURED AND
MUCH MORE FORMAL.
SO ON THE ONE HAND THAT STORY
MAY BE ONE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WANTS TO SEE OUT THERE.
BUT, YES, IT GIVES A WHIFF O